>>> TONIGHT SEVERAL MISSILE
ATTACKS REPORTED ACROSS UKRAINE,
ONE SAYING A CRUISE MISSILE WAS
ON ITS WAY TO KYIV BEFORE BEING
SHOT DOWN.
AS RUSSIA TRIES TO BLOCK
SHIPMENTS OF MILLARY WEAPONS
INTO UKRAINE.
COMES RUSSIA INCREASES ASSAULTS
ON THE STEAL PLANT IN MARIUPOL,
ONE OFFICIAL INSIDE TOLD US 20
CHILDREN WERE THERE LAST NIGHT,
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAYING
MOMENTS AGO, MORE THAN 150 A
ABLE TO GET OUT OF THE PLANT IN
TOTAL AFTER A BRIEF EVACUATION
EFFORT BROKERED BY THE RED
CROSS, ONE FAMILY UNDER THAT
PLANT SINCE MARCH 2nd, TWO
MONTHS AGO, TELLING CNN I NEVER
THOUGHT THE EARTH COULD SHAKE
LIKE THAT, DIDN'T ONLY SHAKE,
THE BUNKER TREMBLED, SURVIVORS
SHARING TRULY HORRIBLE STORIES
AS RUSSIA RAMPS UP ATTACK
AGAINST UKRAINE.
SAM KILEY IS "OUTFRONT."
>> Reporter: SINCE RUSSIAN
ROCKETS DESTROYED HER HOME,
KILLED HER BROTHER, ALL SHE HAS
LEFT IS HER MOTHER AND HER LIFE.
>> Translator: ALL AT ONCE,
STARTED FALLING ONE BY ONE,
THERE ARE EXPLOSIONS EVERYWHERE,
OPPOSITE THE KITCHEN AND HOUSE,
THE WINDOWS AND FRAME, ROOM TO
ROOM.
WE ARE STANDING THERE.
MY BROTHER WAS MAKING THE SIGN
OF THE CROSS AND I'M SHOUTING.
I TURNED AWAY FROM HIM TO LOOK
AT THE HOUSE AND THEN ANOTHER
ROCKET HIT AND I WAS TRAPPED
UNDER RUBBLE.
I CAN'T SEE MY BROTHER ANYMORE.
I FELL AND I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW
I WOKE UP AND STARTED PULLING
MYSELF OUT.
I'M ALL SCRATCHED AND BATTERED.
I YELLED VITA, VITA, BUT HE WAS
GONE.
>> Reporter: HER HOME WAS
FLATTENED DURING THE BATTLE FOR
RUBIZNE NOW IN RUSSIAN HANDS,
RUSSIA'S STATED AIM IS TO
CAPTURE ALL OF THE DONBAS AND
THAT INCLUDES LUHANSK AND
DONETSK PROVINCES, GOVERNOR OF
LUHANSK SAYS UKRAINE CAN HOLD
THE RUSSIANS BACK FOR NOW,
SAYING WE NEED POWERFUL LONG
RANGE ARTILLERY AND
UNFORTUNATELY IS NOT HERE YET
AND COULD CHANGE THE WHOLE WAR.
WITHOUT THE WEAPONS PROMISED BY
THE U.S. AND OTHER WESTERN
ALLIES, HE SAYS, THE RUSSIANS
WILL DESTROY EVERYTHING WITH
ARTILLERY AND MORTARS.
THEY'RE JUST WIPING EVERYTHING
OFF THE FACE OF THE EARTH SO
THERE'S NOTHING LEFT TO HANG ON
TO.
FOR UKRAINE, THIS IS AN
EXISTENTIAL BATTLE.
REENFORCEMENTS ARE BEAK RUSHED
TO THE FRONTLINES BUT THERE'S NO
SIGNS OF THE HEAVY WEAPONS
NEEDED TO BLOCK A RUSSIAN
ADVANCE, MUCH LESS REVERSE IT.
THE DOCTOR SAYS LAMILA WILL BE
MOVED WEST FOR TREATMENT, BUT
THE FATE OF HER AND HER MOTHER
IS UNKNOWN.
WE SIMPLY CANNOT HANDLE SO MANY
WOUNDED WITH SUCH SEVERE
INJURIES HE SAYS.
THIS WOMAN SHELLED THIS MORNING
JOINS THE WARD AND 13 MILLION
OTHER UKRAINIANS FLED THEIR
HOMES TO ESCAPE HER FATE.
>> I WAS LEFT HERE NAKED,
NOTHING AT ALL, NO DOCUMENTS,
NOTHING.
>> Reporter: YET A SMALL VICTORY
OVER PUTIN BECAUSE SHE'S BEEN
NEITHER BAGGERED NOR BEATEN.
NOW UP THE ROAD TOWARD ISIUM,
THE THRUST MADE BY RUSSIANS IS
BEING FOUGHT BACK BY THE
ARTILLERY FIRED BACK AT THEM BY
THE UKRAINIANS, THIS IS NOT JUST
A ONE DIRECTION WAR, THE
UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING BACK
FEROCIOUSLY, THE RUSSIANS MAKE
SMALL INCREMENTAL PROCESS IN THE
NORTHERN FRONT AND I THINK THAT
IS WHY THE GOVERNMENT THERE
UNDERLINED THE CRITICAL NEED FOR
THE MUCH MORE SOPHISTICATED NATO
WEAPONRY THAT COULD REALLY TURN
THE WAR HERE, PUT UKRAINIANS ON
THE FRONT FOOT, ERIN.
>> SAM, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> "OUTFRONT" NOW, U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO THE ORGANIZATION
FOR SECURITY AND COOPERATION IN
EUROPE, USCE, MICHAEL CARPENETER
AND AMBASSADOR, I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TONIGHT.
YOU HAVE BEEN WARNING THAT
RUSSIA IS READY TO ANNEX LUHANSK
AND DONETSK AND COULD DECLARE
KHERSON AN INDEPENDENT REPUBLIC.
WHAT MORE COULD YOU TELL US
ABOUT PUTIN'S PLANS AND THE
TIMING HERE?
>> YEAH, SO THANKS, ERIN, WE
HAVE CREDIBLE INFORMATION THAT
RUSSIA IS PLANNING TO POSSIBLY
ANNEX THESE TWO REGIONS OF
UKRAINE, AS EARLY AS MID MAY AND
THAT THEY ARE LOOKING AT
POSSIBLY CONDUCTING A SHAM
REFERENDUM IN KHERSON OBLAST TO
DECLARE A SO-CALLED PEOPLES'
REPUBLIC SIMILAR TO WHAT THEY'VE
DONE IN DONETSK AND LUHANSK AND
THIS IS PART OF THE KREMLIN'S
PLAYBOOK, WE'VE SEEN THIS
BEFORE.
THEY REPLACED LOCAL OFFICIALS
WITH RUSSIAN PROXIES AND
PUPPETS, CUT CELL PHONE AND
INTERNET COVERAGE SO THEY CAN
STOP RELIABLE INFORMATION
GETTING IN, DECREED THEY'LL USE
THE RUSSIAN RUBLE SO WE'RE
LOOKING CLOSELY TO SEE IF THEY
EXECUTE ON THIS PLAN BUT DO HAVE
INDICATIONS THIS COULD BE AFOOT.
>> AND THAT COULD, YOU KNOW,
SIZABLY, WOULD BE BY THING OFF
LARGER AND LARGER CHUNKS OF
UKRAINE IF THEY DO THIS.
AMBASSADOR, U.S. AND WESTERN
OFFICIALS HAVE ALSO SAID THAT
PUTIN COULD FORMALLY DECLARE WAR
ON MAY 9th AND THAT WOULD, BASE
, BASICALLY ALLOW HIM TO HAVE A
DRAFT, MASS CONSCRIPTION.
PRIME MINISTER OF HUNGARY,
VICTOR ORBAN TOLD HIM THAT PUTIN
ACTUALLY PLANS TO END THE WAR ON
THAT DAY, SORT OF AN IMPORTANT
DAY IN RUSSIAN HISTORY,
PATRIOTIC SO-CALLED VICTORY DAY.
ARE YOU SEEING ANY INDICATION
THAT ORBAN IS CORRECT?
>> WE'RE SEEING, ERIN,
ABSOLUTELY NO INDICATIONS THAT
PUTIN IS ABOUT TO END THIS WAR,
ALTHOUGH IT HAS BEEN AN ABJECT
FAILURE FOR RUSSIA, LOST THE
BATTLE OF KYIV, BUT WE'RE SEEING
ALL IND KGDSS THEY'RE REGROUPING
AND REFOCUSING FORCES IN THE
SOUTH AND EAST.
NO INDICATIONS WHATSOEVER THAT
IS ABOUT TO ABATE.
>> RUSSIAN AMBASSADOR PUTTING
FORWARD NEW NUMBERS, 11,000
UKRAINIANS TAKEN FROM UKRAINE TO
RUSSIA, THESE ARE RUSSIAN
NUMBERS AND THE RUSSIAN DEFENSE
MINISTRY SAYS MORE THAN 1
MILLION UKRAINIANS, 200,000 OF
THEM CHILDREN, HAVE BEEN TAKEN
INTO RUSSIA AND WE KNOW FROM
MANY REPORTS THE 10S OF
THOUSANDS, HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF UKRAINIANS HELD AGAINST THEIR
WILL AT THESE SO-CALLED
FILTRATION CAMPS AND MANY
FORCIBLY BEING TAKEN TO RUSSIA.
WHAT INFORMATION DO YOU HAVE
ABOUT THE FILTRATION CAMPS AND
UKRAINIANS BEING FORCED TO
RUSSIA AGAINST THEIR WILL?
>> WELL WE'RE GETTING A LOT OF
REPORTS OF THESE FILTRATION
CAMPS AND INDEED, THERE HAVE
BEEN EYE-WITNESS ACCOUNTS,
PEOPLE WHO HAVE EITHER MANAGED
TO SOMEHOW ESCAPE OR, I THINK,
IN THE PREPONDERANCE OF CASES,
HAVE BEEN PRISONERS THAT HAVE
BEEN TRADED AND CAME BACK TO
UKRAINE AND HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
TELL THEIR STORIES EITHER TO
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS OR TO THE
INTERNATIONAL MEDIA.
AND THE ACCOUNTS JUST HARROWING,
THEY GO TO THESE FILTRATION
CAMPS, GOD KNOWS WHAT HAPPENS IF
YOU DON'T QUOTE-UNQUOTE PASS, A
LOT OF PEOPLE DISAPPEAR AND
THEY'RE MISSING, WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S HAPPENING TO THEM.
OTHERS COME OUT AND ALLEGED
TORTURE.
SO IT'S JUST INCONCEIVABLE WE
COULD BE TALKING ABOUT THIS IN
THE YEAR 2022 BUT THAT'S THE
REALITY WE'RE SEEING.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THE REAL
NUMBER IS OF UKRAINIANS PUT IN
NEEDS CAMPS, HELD AGAINST THEIR
WILL OR TAKEN TO RUSSIA?
>> IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO SAY IN
THIS STAGE, A LOT OF UNKNOWNS, I
SUSPECT THE FIGURE IS HIGHER
THAN THE ESTIMATES AT THIS TIME
AND SIMILARLY, WHEN THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY GETS
ACCESS TO THE CITY OF MARIUPOL,
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE THERE I
THINK IS GOING TO BE ABSOLUTELY
HARROWING AND HORRIFYING AND WE
ALL SAW THE IMAGES FROM BU